okay so i guess i'll start here hi
hello everybody um my name is philip
carter
uh i work at microsoft on the fsharp
and dotnet compilers team um or rather
it's the.net team and there's like
different sub teams and one of those sub
teams has some
sharp and compiler stuff and that's sort
of what we're working on
um i've been working in the space for
the past
four years now um focusing a lot on
fsharp and kind of helping drive some of
the more
modern things that we've been doing with
the language and
um i'm excited to talk to you today
about
you know a different topic one that i've
i've never actually
given before and one that i hope to be
speaking a lot more about in the future
um i call this talk f sharp as a better
python
but uh it's it's more it's it's pretty
much just going to be about fsharp it's
not really going to be talking about
python very much and i'm not going to be
spending a lot of time doing like this
side-by-side comparison of like oh
actually here's f sharp code look how
better it is in the c-sharp code and you
know it's
i find that to oftentimes be a little
bit unproductive like it can be helpful
but um don't get me wrong about that but
i'm kind of more interested in python as
a means to accomplishing things in a
given space
and how fsharp can fulfill that same
need
and i personally think that f sharp can
do a lot of these things better than
python which is
what i want to end up focusing on so
um first let me talk about f sharp
kind of in a nutshell uh very briefly so
f sharp it's we call it the functional
language for net it's functional
programming language runs on.net it's
been running on.net for a long time
um runs on the core runs across platform
yada yada yada
um but what i think what's a little bit
interesting is the code
f code looks a lot more like python than
it does c sharp
right c sharp code looks absolutely
nothing like this but a lot of python
code is surprisingly similar
like from a syntactical standpoint which
is one of the reasons why i think some
people who are familiar with python
might find themselves enjoying
uh using f sharp code and so on the
left-hand side we
actually have a web application running
on asp.net core
with a library called giraffe and what's
interesting is giraffe is this fantastic
um library that was inspired by a
different library called suave a while
ago
and um what it does is it sort of takes
this this functional programming nature
of you know focusing on functions
focusing on inputs and outputs and it
lifts that
in directly into the routing
abstractions right so an api route in a
web application for example is actually
just a function that accepts an input
and then produces an output
and it's very similar to how you know
http works right it's you're
really reasoning about inputs and
outputs and so that's what goes on here
and it ends up working out very very
well
and on the right hand side uh here's an
example of using some types for
numeric uh stuff uh this s map is kind
of a sliceable map it's a it's a custom
data type in the library where i
pulled some code from um and what's
interesting is
this is all about um
let's see it looks like my my screen got
booted here sorry about that
um so
the this these sort of like list
comprehension sort of things that you
can do be sort of being able to generate
data on the fly slice it and index it on
the fly this is a sort of thing that's
actually fairly common especially if
you're doing numeric style programming
in f sharp
um and again it's sort of pythonic and
it's a very different way of programming
compared to
say c sharp or java or basic or things
like that
and so that's why you know this talk
isn't about f sharp is a better c sharp
it's sharp as a better pilot because
um it looks pythonic and as i'll go into
it a little bit more
we're exploring spaces that python
excels in today
and uh making the case that f sharp can
be used
in those same places so
the first one which i think is perhaps
the most important to talk about in the
beginning is f-sharp for the web
because shocker python is also used for
the web it's
incredibly popular for building web
applications actually
um between django and
uh flask i think those two libraries
alone
account for the the lion's share of
python usage on the web and you know
entire businesses are built on this
stuff
well fsharp can be used for the web too
and not only can it be used for the web
it's actually really really good
on the web especially on the server and
that's because it relies on asp.net core
which is the high performance web server
for net
uh it's incredibly mature but also very
extensible
the extensibility part is important
because not only does it run fast
but it allows you to build bindings on
top of it that sort of makes
you know allow you to use more than just
like the base abstractions and the base
you know nbc abstractions that come with
you know a typical c-sharp application
running on asp.net core
in fact there's three libraries that i
want to call out in particular giraffe
saturn and falco all three um
take advantage of asp.net core
extensibility
and use um features in fsharp that
really sort of like
highlight the differences and and make
it you know feel like it's really native
to f sharp
um the other thing that's important is f
sharp is full access to the modern.net
ecosystem
so all of our libraries and sdks that
you would expect to be able to work in
pretty much every single major
environment uh you can
you can get that to work in f sharp
consume all these libraries you can
produce libraries that you know
c-sharp developers can consume if you if
you need that to
happen for your business um fsharp is
fantastic on the server
in fact um uh
i would say that it's in some ways
better
than python um you know benchmarks you
can you can always fudge a benchmark you
can make some stuff look way better than
other things but
um we found that the uh tech and power
benchmarks are pretty good
overall it's pretty hard to cheat in
those things um
and f sharp outperforms python in a
large variety of tests across different
test runs
uh this is zebra and giraffe these are
two frameworks zebra is a bit more
experimental but giraffe is
is something that a lot of people use
their businesses today um
if you want performance you can use
f-sharp and you won't have to worry
about it
which i think matters a lot
but f-sharp isn't just for like the web
server side
of doing web development you can
actually compile f-sharp to javascript
and there's two major projects that sort
of enable that that i would encourage
you to check out
um the first is called fable fable is
this open source project that was
started a few years ago and its focus
on um it it literally takes actually the
f-sharp compiler itself and it takes the
fsharp syntax
tree converts it into a javascript
syntax streak and then from that point
on
you you're using f-sharp but you're
operating in a different context
right you're not you're not in net you
know transpiling and
emitting some garbage javascript that
like hopefully a browser is able to
you know do something with um when
you're using a library
in a fable application you're using an
npm library
you're not using new yet um when
you're producing a library you're
producing an npm package
um when you're building your application
you're using javascript based building
tools
um when you are you know testing stuff
out in the browser they have like you
know this hot reload sort of thing and
you can you can um or rather i think
it's called hot module reload where you
can
update just a tiny part of the ui and
have only that part refresh in your
browser to make sure that it's all
working
it's all based off of javascript tool
and you're you're you're using f sharp
but you're living fundamentally in the
javascript world
this model view update app architecture
is this thing that was uh
pioneered actually by the elm
programming language but was brought
into fsharp via fable
and has since become a fairly popular
way to build
applications in the ashrae community uh
the other project that i want to call
out for
using fsharp with you know to sort of
produce javascript that you can
run in the browser is web sharper which
is it's been around for a very long time
um it's sort of changed as the web has
changed
and as that sharp has changed um but
it's an enterprise-grade full-stack
f-sharp development experience where you
have f-sharp on the server and
f-sharp on the client they can talk to
each other and it all just works
um there's sort of a bit of a the way
that i'll contrast them
because they're both great is fable is
more about you kind of assembling your
own stack
to sort of fit your own needs and web
sharper is sort of this you know hey you
got the batteries included
turnkey you can just start going and you
have a great support contract for the
company that
um builds web sharper and so it's
important because
you know a lot of developers frankly
don't like writing javascript code
um javascript isn't like horrible or
anything but it's got some parts that
are not that great
and when you use fsharp instead of
javascript you end up having
a much better time because it's it's a
bit more sound as as a language
um but it's also
not just about javascript because fsharp
can also compile to webassembly
the same folks that have built web
sharper have also built a project called
bolero which is where
actually a lot of their focus is right
now um you use the same app architecture
model view update which you can see a
little bit
of an example here um but instead of
transpiling to javascript and then you
know being interpreted by your browser
that sort of stuff it just
it's actually fsharp.net code itself
that is then run
via webassembly um and it has full hot
reloading support as well which is
pretty great
it's actually based off of some lower
level components of blazer so
as blazer evolves and gets better bolero
also evolves and gets better
basically for free um and there's no
javascript involved
it's pretty great it's it's a really
cool thing that i encourage you to check
out especially if you want to try out
webassembly so
um is great
on the server if you if you want to sort
of avoid some of the problems with
javascript if you will
you can have fsharp compile the
javascript and you have a couple of
different choices that are pretty great
and if you want to blaze some new trails
a little bit
you can use f-sharp with web assembly
for your uis and this is something that
i'm very actually very excited to see
spring up in the fr community and
as this web assembly stuff gets better i
think we're going to be able to make a
legitimate case that you can
eliminate most of your javascript and
just legitimately write
f sharp code completely end to end and
have all in my sort of understanding
so i want to take a brief aside about
how we got here because i'm going to
talk more about this python stuff later
um but everything that i told you about
so far was aligned with dynacorp
and this slide is called recent f sharp
history but it might as well
say net core f sharp history because
that's really what this is all about
right over the past about four years now
if you count the development leading up
to f sharp 4.1
um we have been focused almost
exclusively on making sure that fsharp
is great
and so in 2017 we released initial
support with that and along with some
other
languages about a year and a half later
with that sharp 4.5
came some low-level programming support
for don accord cord be able to do
use span of t use bireflex trucks be
able to do
the high performance coding that you
need to do sometimes
a few months later we released f sharp
4.6 which included anonymous records a
feature that is is one of those that you
find yourself using
a lot and you don't really think about
it you just sort of it's
you're just sort of programming and boom
oh i could use an anonymous record i'll
just do that and
move on and a lot of uh visual studio
ide performance
work and then a few months later after
that f sharp 4.7 released with
importantly preview feature
infrastructure so we have the ability
now with the fsr compiler to be able to
release preview features
alongside a released f sharp compiler
allow you to toggle a flag and say hey
i'm going to use preview features
try it out and they even give us
feedback on if these preview features
make sense
if you think that we made the right
decisions um
and we can make adjustments you know and
and then eventually sort of once we feel
like a given preview feature is
good enough from a design and
implementation standpoint to promote to
a full language feature we can do that
and that's actually the first thing
that's happening with f sharp 4.5 uh
sorry f sharp 5.0
when i say lots of things i i really
mean actually lots of preview features
that are going to be promoted to
um non-preview here pretty shortly and
so this is all about recent f sharp
history
it's sort of like uh an era if you will
like the.net core era
but i'm going to make the case that f
sharp five
which we're releasing later in this fall
is the end of that era
and it's going to be the start of a new
one that isn't to say that we're done
with fsharp and dot-net core and making
sure that f-sharp is great on the server
and
you know all these things that you could
do with python and c-sharp on the server
to build web applications like
there's still work that needs to go on
go into that there's still bug fixes
there's still some
little tweaks that we could make in fact
there's even a new feature that we're
thinking of shipping next year instead
of this year that will make things even
better
um but largely our goals there were to
make sure that f sharp is awesome with
donut core and
really that sort of means making sure
that f sharp is great cross-platform for
building modern applications
um which i think is really important in
this day and age
but that work is sort of
largely complete in a way um i
and so you know the work is never done
but our major our goals have been mostly
accomplished and so there's sort of this
question of well
what do we do next right um
you could oversimplify it and say go
after the space of the python is going
but you know it's
it's a little bit more nuanced than that
and i'll try to communicate that here
so f sharp five
i'm not really going to say like what
exactly f sharp five is
because uh people the way that people
interpret a language
is sort of it's really sort of up to
them but i will say that we emphasize
sort of three major things uh
interactive programming
analytical workloads and what i'm
calling great fundamentals
great fundamentals kind of like
hand-wavy
you know okay cool you're just making
sure that it's good um
well what i mean by that is interactive
programming and analytical workloads
those are like specific things
that all that i'll be explaining a
little bit here
and great fundamentals means that we're
not just going to graft on something
that like takes a box on a checklist for
interactive programming or analytical
workloads said ah yes we've accomplished
this moving on now
it's about very thoughtfully
incorporating things
so that you know interactive programming
and doing
analytical stuff with f-sharp is better
than it was before
but in a way that you're using features
that are generally useful to people
and not only useful for people who are
in you know that particular bucket
of you know i'm doing data science i get
my data science feature very cool
um we're trying to be very thoughtful
with this because
languages are permanent in terms of once
you add things to them you can't just go
rip out a feature because people depend
on it
and so we want to make sure that we do
the right thing and we do it
carefully but and thoughtfully so
this is what we emphasize
so interactive and analytical does
that sound at all familiar to anyone
here
related to python python completely owns
this space today there is no question
that if you're doing interactive
programming and analytical work
you're either going to be you're either
using python already or you're going to
be using python at some point that's
just
that's just the way that the world is
today and
i don't know if we all sort of know
exactly how it got there i have my own
hypotheses related to very gradual
growth and
you know very careful building of
libraries that make sense for people
over a very long period of time and
you know have that finally be recognized
over the past five years
um but the fact of the matter is if
you're doing interactive programming
with say jupyter notebooks you're
probably using python
and this is important because it's not
just programmers and data scientists
people doing machine learning who are
doing this this is this is people in
education this is people
in the sciences who may not necessarily
view
their programming language as you know a
way to build applications but rather as
a way to
learn something about the domain that
they're operating in
this is something that in particular um
you know fsharp has been okay yet
but net as a whole has not really been
very good at
right.net has always been about building
applications
um but there's this entire group of
programmers that
is growing a lot and they're not really
building applications they're really
sort of using code as
a means to an end and yes maybe maybe
things get incorporated into an
application right
maybe you're a data scientist who you
have a math background
um and you write a little bit of code
and you help your software developers to
incorporate a model that you built into
the greater application that's totally
fine
um but this is important this is what we
want to go after
because we think this is a way to grow
net this is a way to grow f sharp
especially in a way that is unique from
c sharp
you know we're not you know having to
sort of ride on the coattails of c sharp
and donna core we can say aha we're here
we're in a place we want to be
let's go after some people where we
think we can truly excel
so interactive programming
interactivity and programming is sort of
like you know you're not building an
application you're building something
that well you interact with
you're you're constantly sort of
adjusting it and getting it to a point
where you sort of want to do things and
and believe it or not f sharp has quite
a history here uh this is a wonderful
little picture of using
f sharp with visual studio on windows xp
very old
i believe this is visual studio 2005. uh
and this is actually the f-sharp
interactive process
um it's sort of see it at the bottom of
the picture there
uh generating a surface plot right so
this has been actually been around for
quite a while
um being able to you can reference
assemblies with f-sharp interactive
today
you can load other f-sharp scripts and
sort of load them into the context of
you know the thing that you're operating
in
and maybe have multiple scripts that do
certain certain tasks
you break up the work that way and
there's id integration and visual studio
and now visual studio code and uh jeff
range writer
and other ids as well
there's also more than just f sharp
interactive in fact the ether community
has built
actually a jupiter kernel back in the
day called ifsharp that is still
maintained a little bit by one of the
fine folks at microsoft research
um and i'll talk about how that's sort
of going to be obviated by
uh you know some some product work that
we're doing here
um the fable project that i mentioned
before has
an online reply that allows you to
interactively build out a ui
entirely within your browser and there
have been other ides that have focused
on interactivity over the years
in the sharp community
so it's not like this is entirely new
ground that we're treading here
but what's worth calling out
is from microsoft's perspective right
you know microsoft engineers have built
out
f-sharp interactive the core
infrastructure that enabled certain
things
but then around 2014 i'd say
it kind of just stopped um that isn't to
say that it was the wrong thing to do
right you know there was a lot of work
that had to go into supporting.core and
you know we ultimately think that was
the right decision
but we hadn't really invested in core
interactive experiences
right we had built lower level
infrastructure but then sort of just
left it there
um this is something that we want to
pick up again because we think this is
sort of a new frontier for
uh getting people to try out f sharp and
functional programming and dot net
so with f sharp five we're doing the
first bit of this
so we're dialing it up a notch you can
see on the right hand side
there's a screenshot of a jupiter
notebook where
i'm referencing a package
newtonsoft.json any
net developer should probably know
exactly what that is
what you notice here is i didn't there's
no there's no like you know oh behind
the scenes
philip must have you know run some
command on his machine and
and done this sort of thing and then he
you know he's lying right i can't just
literally say pound our nougat colin
newton.json and then just get
newtonsoft.json can i well
the answer actually is yes you can um
and i'll show you that a little bit here
the other thing is it's not just about
being able to reference nuget packages
but we want to focus on
overall experiences not just low-level
infrastructure
but high-level what you're doing inside
of jupiter notebooks and vs code
notebooks
um the jupiter notebook support is
fairly
stable at this point vs code notebooks
is a bit um
there's a lot more work that has to go
into those experiences which we're
hoping to release later this year with
five in november
um but i personally think the vs code
stuff is
really awesome and so that's what i want
to demo
so let me pull up visual studio code
so i have this file on the left hand
side
it's a dot dib uh this is the file
extension used for
for vs code notebooks let me go ahead
and open this
so before i go through exact you know
all of this sort of stuff
actually just let me close this so
you're not uh distracted here
one thing i want to call out is all i've
done is installed visual studio code
insiders i went to my extensions
um i i downloaded this uh rainbow csv
thing
because it it makes csvs nicer to work
with
but actually all i've gone and done is
i've installed a single plugin
called.net interactive notebooks
this is a preview plugin so you know
it's so well previewed
it won't be later this year um but
that's it i didn't have to do anything
special
i didn't have to go and download you
know i didn't have to make a decision
between if i want to use
docker containers pie end anaconda
mini conda to be able to get a stable
environment to do stuff
i just had to download a single
extension and that's it
and so when i open up one of these files
uh this is the very first time what it
does is it goes and
it downloads all of the necessary
dependencies and places them in an
isolated location
and knows how to point them there and
then boom you're there so
let's go through some of the stuff that
we can do here with f sharp
and actually interestingly enough the
first thing i'm going to do is execute
some powershell rather than that sharp
i could have written this code to
download these three csvs
in fsharp but it just so happens that
the act of downloading a file
and placing it somewhere on your machine
is extremely optimized in powershell
it's just
so little powershell to actually do that
so i just went ahead and did that
so i'm going to execute that cell and
boom you can see on the left hand side i
get some csvs
so here's this confirmed recovery this
is some coveted data
that um we pulled off of some john
hopkins uh github repo here
so we got the data
let's do some stuff with it so the first
thing is i'm actually going to be
supplying a type extension for um
something this is to enable something i
want to do later it's probably going to
add this to the f-sharp core library so
you don't have to do this
but so i've downloaded the video
but now i need to clean it up a little
bit so
how do you do this well open up some
name spaces
systems like regular expressions
and um
looks like we got some noise coming in
the top here
you know from rick is there a way to
mute
no it doesn't
um sorry about that excuse me reagan it
looks like your mic is on
here your keyboard clacking
okay so um anyways i can have
a function that i'm going to call clean
in this case i'm just taking a single
parameter path i'm going to read that
into
a just sort of the raw csv i'm going to
create a regex
and i'm going to just replace some stuff
with the regex and then i'm going to
write that back into the file
then i'm just going to call that
function for confirm.csv
death.csv and recover.csv
then i'm going to admit a string so i'll
run that all cleaned up
okay so it modified those files
cleaned them up a little bit so that i
can do stuff with it so moving on now i
have a little markdown
script here um what's great is you can
actually just read this as a document
after it's all completed
so now we're going to load it into a
data frame well how do i get a data
frame well
let's install one with nuget
all right so it went ahead and it
downloaded microsoft.data.analysis which
is a preview package for doing
well data analysis as the name would
suggest
let's go ahead and do some stuff with
that so there's a little bit more code
here
i'm going to load each of these csvs
into a data frame called desk recovered
and confirmed and recovered and then i'm
going to
set a display value this display
function is kind of like this magic
function that we have
in interactive and it's just going to
say processing data
and i'm going to do some stuff um it's
kind of a for loop here this this offset
thing if you'll notice the reason why
that's there
is um there's like one two
three four there's like zero one two
three and then four and then this is
some date information this is
what we're after here so we wanna when
we're reading the csv we want to
initially ignore
these these first columns here so
that's what's going to be going on
all right
cool so um going to be doing just a
simple for loop here
you know for i equals offsetdef.coms.com
there's probably a number of different
ways you could write this but you know
for loop is pretty easy to understand
i'm going to extract the current date
that i'm looking at i'm going to look at
the
the desks the confirmed cases and the
recovered cases that are based off of
um you know the current position and
each cf csv that i'm in
and then just going to display a value
in the notebook itself saying hey this
is the thing that we're processing right
now
and then i'm going to produce an object
so this is an f sharp anonymous record
notice that it's denoted by this this
little curly bracket sort of thing right
here
so this whole thing is a record and it's
actually containing
other records inside of it so the first
is it's going to just have a thing
called date which is just the date
there's going to be debts associated
with that date
those deaths are going to have you know
um it's sort of going to be like this
there's going to be a latitude a
longitude and a you know some data
basically confirmed cases and recovery
cases are the exact same thing it's just
they're going to be looking at data
inside of these
um confirm.csv and recovered.csv files
and then what i'm going to do is there's
this it's called a resize array it's
it's
sort of the same thing as a
system.collections.generic of list of t
and i'm just going to go ahead and add
the instance of this data that
constructed inside of this for loop to
the series
and it's going to do that for you know
every value inside the csv
and then when i'm done it's just going
to print onto the screen so i'll execute
that
processing a bunch of different dates
and it's done cool all right
that's pretty simple so now i have
everything
loaded into my series
so let's go ahead and try plot so what
i'm actually going to be
using is a library called xplot
xpot ultimately compiles stuff down
into javascript and then that javascript
is going to be using a javascript
plotting library called
plotly so the first thing is i'm going
to construct this layout object
this is the sort of thing that it's kind
of it's a little bit fuzzy because
you know you've got to learn the
specifics of the library to really make
much use out of it but ultimately i'm
going to want to
um produce what's called a scattered geo
right so there's going to be a layout
there's going to be a font a title sort
of a background color
um what the the geo is in this case it's
sort of like a
you know a picture of the world and
we're going to be placing some stuff
on it and so in this case you'll notice
the scatter geo there's going to be a
name a mod
geos called geo latitude
longitude text marker this is where data
is going to be coming from
in this case there's you know in the
series i'm just going to look at the
very first item
and i'm going to get you know this is
i'm basically looking at recovered cases
so the first recovered case and where
that is
all right so displayed a big old map
here and
no surprise the first covered the first
recovered case is in mainland of china
where the
virus originated from so
let's say i wanted to look at the
last data in the series
typing a special character here
this is the reverse index stuff
that's kind of from up here this is
saying
that i want to look at zero from the end
basically the last item
we'll take a look at that and there's a
whole lot more
recoveries as you would imagine because
this is the last item in the data set
from
um 6 10 20 at least in the data that
we're looking at and i don't think
that's quite
um probably not a hundred percent
representative or
maybe it is there's a bunch of data here
there's ways to like kind of clean up
this plot
but i think what's important to sort of
note here is
i'm just writing some f sharp code i'm
not and like i can pull in multiple
libraries and i don't really have to
worry about it
i can just install an environment really
simply
i can start writing some code and it
works with with these tools directly
which is pretty great and um just for
good measure
say i want to convert this into an ipymb
file this is actually the jupiter
notebooks
file format so that i could share it
with say maybe i have a co-worker
who's not using vs code notebooks
they're actually using jupyter lab which
is uh sort of an ide for um
jupyter notebooks well i could work in
this case do all my stuff in f sharp
i could then just export it as an ipy b
file
and then all they have to do is just
make sure that they have the f-sharp
kernel installed
um in their environment which is
actually just as simple as installing a
single global tool called.net
interactive
and that will actually go ahead and
install all the language kernels and
they can just work directly with this
ipymb file
let's go back here
so a few things to sort of uh summarize
with that
so acquisition and installation is very
very simple
for using f-sharp with notebooks right
um
for those of you who have done any like
serious work in python
you're probably well aware that it is
very easy to potentially corrupt your
system installation
um so you have to install a given
environment
right and so you know oftentimes you're
just going to be installing an anaconda
or midi content depending on your needs
but there's a lot of choices that you
have to make and you kind of got to be
careful
additionally and i didn't i didn't
really call this out very much but say
you are in a jupiter notebook
with by doing python work today and you
have to use a package that's not
a part of say your anaconda distribution
right it's external to that distribution
that's
perhaps unlikely but you still you may
you may be in that environment
well you have two choices you could stop
your work in
the notebook you could install that
dependency into that environment
and then restart your work and go on and
do that kind of
you know take a break and do that or you
could know some magic code that you have
to type
inside of your pie sorry inside of your
notebook
that um we'll use your your pip
installation to go ahead and install it
for you but it has to do it safely and
so you have to know exactly how to do
that safely and there's a
it's kind of high friction that's not a
problem that you have when you're not
sharper notebooks with it which i think
is pretty important
the other thing is um i didn't show this
off very i didn't show this off at all
actually but
interoperability is something that we're
doing being able to interrupt with c
sharp and f sharp
it's actually supported today there's a
few quirks
um but you know i can export a value
from f sharp and consume it inside of a
c sharp cell inside of the same notebook
i can do that um in vs code notebooks i
can also do that in jupiter notebooks
and that's something that we're
hardening for the release so that we can
interoperate cleanly between the two
languages
the other thing that's worth calling out
is it's not just about c-sharp and
f-sharp and raw
um let's say i didn't want to use
plotley and i wanted to use a different
say javascript based uh plotting library
well i could actually do that uh there's
a way that you can export
um just f sharp values and have them be
they're siri they in the background they
get serialized as json
and then you can import that from say
just some javascript code inside of a
javascript cell
this is something that we have working
to some degree right now there's i'm
operating off of a dev build i've been a
little bit nervous trying to uh
uh do that i think the first preview of
this is going to be releasing fairly
soon and then we'll have that capability
in there
um but we also want to extend that to
python
so it then becomes not really a question
of
f sharp versus python but f sharp
alongside python
right because the reality is python has
incredible library support
that you would be a fool not to use in
you know a number of circumstances
but you may prefer f sharp for like i
don't know like maybe cleaning and
interpreting your data but then say you
want to plot it and there's a particular
python clotting library that you really
love
or say it's the inverse um you have some
python data but then you want to consume
it in in
f sharp and do something else with it um
using a common interface with uh json
serialization inside of the notebook and
be able to just sort of what we call do
variable sharing is something that we're
striving to do here and this is all
going to be going ga
um in this fall you know if everything
goes well so this is something that
we're definitely very excited to
do here so
there's more to interactive programming
there's more i could have shown you but
you know i don't want to run over time
so the other thing that i sort of called
out explicitly about five analytical
workloads
it's kind of a weird phrase so what does
that mean well
um first thing that i did is i shopped
for three stock images of people looking
like they're thinking
um you can tell that they're very deep
in thought here
uh just as i was pondering what
analytical workloads meant but so what i
really mean by that
is you know sort of all of the above
with respect to
data access manipulating data analyzing
data
doing some machine learning or we call
it ai if we're talking to people who are
you know
not familiar with the term um sometimes
just a bunch of math stuff
right and like math stuff that can be
like you know for game development
or it can be for you know all sorts of
like math is sort of everywhere and
especially for i mean machine learning
is really just math actually so
um that's something that's growing math
is growing you got to be good at that
stuff if you
operate in space uh that's sort of what
this this whole thing means and
it's not really new right you know all
these things like data access and data
manipulation it's been around forever
anybody who's been doing any serious
database work knows exactly what that's
all about they just use a different
language called sql
this is something that sharp has also
been pretty good at over the years
that we want to emphasize and make
better
right so specifically in terms of f
sharp five this sort of question what
does it mean
right you say okay philip you want to go
off and do this all this math stuff
cool but like what does that actually
mean um
well the first thing is we want to make
working with collections built-in
collection types just a little bit
easier
we want to interoperate with some
new.net initiatives pretty well right
ml.net spark.net the data frames library
they use some specific constructs that
preview prior to f sharp five used to be
a little bit more
awkward to work with we want to make
that less awkward um
another thing is we want to give library
authors who want to work in this space
better tools for abstraction
right um the lifeblood of this
space in python is its libraries and so
by extension that also has to be true
for f sharp
right f sharp needs to have good
libraries coming from people who are
passionate about this space and we want
to make sure that they have the tools to
actually do that
right so they're not fighting against
the language at every step trying to do
what they want to do
and finally um we want to translate f
sharp to some different environments
right we have some ongoing research work
right now about executing
sharp code as what we call ai models and
translating the syntax tree into a pi
torch environment and then running it
there but what's interesting is
in that translation we actually retain
all of the type safety that fdr gets
today that you don't have when you're
using python
um similarly we want to run on a more
common uh model format which where
you know a lot of the industry is
centralizing on onyx
um to do that sort of thing we're going
to make sure f sharp runs
very very well on the onyx runtime
so more
demo time about f sharp five specific
stuff
okay so i had this coved.dib i'm just
gonna close that
go.net interactive and i'm going to
convert
a jupyter notebook to a dot net
interactive notebook
let's go ahead and find it
sharp five we'll call that
sharp five dot dib
all right so i had this ipy and b file
jupyter notebooks by the way when you
don't have the ui they're just a big old
blob of
uh of json but now i have that
sharp5.dib
and boom oh look at that that looks a
lot nicer
so um this is actually a jupiter
notebook that i've been
uh sharing with people since the very
first preview of f sharp five
um that i'll sort of walk through
because it shows
some pretty cool stuff so what we've
seen before be able to
reference a package in fsharp
interactive and execute it
in this case same thing download
newtons.json use it
i'm constructing an f sharp anonymous
record i'm serializing that
i get it back as output pretty
straightforward
let me blow that up
just a little bit bigger okay cool so
one of the things that we're doing
concretely is better interrupt with
mobile value types
right um they've typically been a bit of
a pain in f sharp it's not that you know
they were like incorrect or anything
like that it's just they were perhaps a
little bit too
correct right there's a very strong
motivation to use notable value types
when you're working with
uh data sciencey sort of stuff um
and you had to be very explicit about
what you were doing
in um f sharp prior to uh
f sharp five right there's two lines of
code that i'm just going to ask you here
this is there's no output i'm just sort
of compiling but what's what's important
is i'm creating this thing called the
primitive data frame column
of type time the actual values inside of
that
are not date times they are nullable
value types
that it may be null or date time and so
prior to f sharp five
if i wanted to add one i had to actually
call nullable you know parameterize with
date time and then pass in the value and
do that every single time it's kind of
annoying
and so we just have this sort of type
directed rule is what we call it where
we just sort of say like hey we see that
this thing is a nullable of this thing
you're passing in one of these things so
we'll just construct the nullable for
you
um this is something that it's
not like the biggest fanciest flashiest
feature but it's one of those that
you know you you just feel like the
language is working with you as you're
working with that package
so moving on there oh my cats are
yelling i don't know if you can hear
that but they desperately want inside of
the room that i'm working in right now
um so
the next important one is what we're
calling tolerant and consistent slices
right so basically there used to be some
just dumb behavior
in f sharp if you thought about it right
so this is some
some horribly contrived code that is
obviously nonsensical
right i have i have a a list an array
and a string
that i've constructed and i want to
extract a slice from negative two to
negative one
that that's just nonsense right and i'm
going to get the length
well so the one problem that we had
paradise sharp five is lists would not
throw but then arrays and strings would
throw if you did that
we're actually going to move them to not
throw and the reason why
is because empty lists in f sharp
composed with lists
right you can add an empty less to an
existing list it just works
same thing with raise same thing with
strings we felt like it made sense
another one is we have built in 3d and
4d array slice types
it looks like this markdown table
doesn't format it's unfortunate
but so basically you could imagine a
three-dimensional array
you know going from zero one two three
four five six seven where zero one two
three
are in uh one z dimension and then four
five six and seven
or in another or another z dimension and
let's say i'm giving an instance of this
array
and i want to extract a slice of four or
five
i want to get this vector out of this
three dimensional array sort of question
of okay well how do i do that
well there's slicing syntax to do that
but prior to f sharp five you couldn't
actually do this
um very well you had to write some
custom code
so in this case i'm just gonna fill up
an array or a matrix i guess i'm calling
it
and just giving it that same data and
then i'm to extract the four five slice
all this is doing is saying i don't care
about the
the x dimension i want the zeroth and
the y dimension
i want the the the zero value in the y
dimension and then i want
the the fir the value in the first
dimension
sorry the fir the value in the first
thingy of the the z dimension sorry it's
a little early in the morning so my
uh my words get a little slurred here
um but so anyways as you can see this
extracts a four five vector
um which is exactly what we wanted prior
to f sharp five you could not write this
line of code
this is just one of those things that
you know if you're coming from python
you kind of expect these things to sort
of just work
and this is what um we're striving for
we're also doing from the end slicing
and indexing so in this case i have
another list from one to ten
and i get one element from the end boom
i just do that it's the value nine it's
exactly what you would expect
um and let's say i want to compare
the the old style with the new style
prior to f sharp five you had to write
this nonsense
i had to go you know this x's dot length
minus two and then dot dot which
basically says everything from
this point up until the end
now i can just go from one from the end
or you know i could change that instead
of one it could be x from the end
and you can imagine that
okay so you see they produce the same
value what's interesting is it's not
just
built-in types that support this right i
can actually
take a type that i don't own right span
of t
this is this is defined in uh dot net
core
and i can extend it to provide an f
sharp slice
and provide a reverse index this is
would be a type extension
this is where things start to get very
interesting especially for
library authors because some people are
going to be working with data types that
they did not define themselves
but they want to be able to do useful
things with them well as a library
author and actually even as a consumer
of a library you can provide that stuff
for yourself
and be in a good place so in this case
and the output's a little weird but it's
basically i'm slicing up a spam
that i have constructed and i'm doing it
in two different ways and producing the
exact same output this is
silly code but just sort of showing that
you can do this
another one is the name of function if
you're coming from c sharp you know
exactly what this is
in this case i have a list of months so
i'm going to look up a month by an index
an integer i could be out of bounds and
so in the case of being out of bounds i
want to throw an exception
and i want to have some interesting
stuff inside of that value so
in this case the 12th month is december
1st is january
the 13th doesn't exist that should throw
an exception indeed it does
and i get parameter name month this is
exactly what i wanted
i can take the name of pretty much
anything in fsharp i can take the name
of a function of a module
of a parameter of you know all sorts of
different stuff
can also open static classes in f sharp
five
i can open system and just extract the
value pi
directly from there it's a little
awkward but i can actually define my own
uh um static class and f sure a static
class is actually just a class that's
abstract and sealed so that's how you do
it in that sharp code
in this case i can call add with the
value 2.0 and pi
um and add as defined as a static method
on the static class a
boom that's adding 2.0 to the value pi
that we had earlier
the last one is something that i will
post a link to so that people can read
this because
it's kind of conceptually heavy but the
main thing
to sort of take away from this with
applicative computation expressions
which
big fancy words um is uh this is another
tool for library authors
to offer more expressive libraries for
people to work with
in fact here i have a full um
sort of mini mini library for the result
type that we have built inside of that
sharp dot core
and i can operate on it
using some special syntax called let
bang and bing and bain
and prior to f sharp five i could do
this
the completion is a little funny there
so i could do this
right prior to f sharp five but this and
bang
is a little bit different what it
basically means is that
um it's a way to sort of tell the
compiler that each of these computations
that are happening here are entirely
independent of one another
i cannot have one of these depend on the
other one and so what's important is
that restriction actually buys you a
little bit because you can
enforce a kind of safety if you will for
consumers of the library
and then on top of that it actually
allows the compiler to optimize things
to be a little bit faster
so that's what we got there there's more
demo stuff here
again i'll i'll make sure that there's
links to this stuff for people to play
around with because you're really going
to understand it best when you start
executing code and reading all about it
so there's quite a lot that's going on
here
there's actually some very recent work
that just got merged in
where we allow you to translate a sharp
code to a gpu and execute it there
unfortunately i couldn't get the dev
build of that to work
well enough in conjunction with
everything else on my machine and
i didn't want to spend a ton of time you
know constructing this rube goldberg
machine and then have it
accidentally fall apart right in front
of my face
as i'm giving talk so uh you know
perhaps in a future talk
later this year or maybe next year i'll
have a very compelling
uh executing code in different
environments
so there's a few overall takeaways
i think that you know if you watch this
or what are the main things that i that
i sort of want you to
you know walk away with so firstly i
think f sharp and python share a few
similarities
right one of the main things that
is apparent especially when you're
writing f sharp code is that you don't
write a whole lot of code
similar to python right you can get a
lot of stuff done without a whole lot of
work
um working with collections it's
generally pretty convenient we've made
it even more convenient with five and
we're hoping to find even more ways to
make it convenient in the future
and we're laying the groundwork um or
rather i should say the groundwork has
mostly already been laid for an
excellent library ecosystem it just
needs a few more things
uh and that's something that we're
focusing on with f sharp five because
ultimately if you're if you're operating
the spaces interactivity
and analytical analytical stuff that
python is
excelling at today you need to have a
good library ecosystem
and that's something that we recognize
and we are
working to sort of unblock people
because that way we can enable the
the sr community and people who are just
getting started with f-sharp to be as
creative as they need to be
so when i say fsharp is a better python
it's more about operating in the same
space that python operates in
and i personally think that even today
it does a lot of things better than
python
um i think that over the next
year two years and especially three
years that's going to become very true
as we focus more and more on this
and that sharp five is really the first
step in
in making it awesome for interactive and
analytical programming
um so i'm sort of saying that fsr5 marks
sort of a new era for the language that
isn't to say that fsharp is you know you
shouldn't do web programming anymore or
you should only use it for science and
machine learning and all that sort of
stuff
um because you know python isn't used
exclusively for those things either
so we think it's already great for the
web
we think it's going to become even
better for interactive and analytical
programming
and the next version of f sharp extra
five and then the following versions
coming after that
it's gonna be even better at least
that's what we're what we're shouting
for
so if you wanna get started today just
try things out
you know see where there are gaps tell
us what those gaps are that sort of
stuff
um you can get started there's just a
simple link aka dot ms slash
f sharp home uh what this does this
takes you to the fsharp homepage on the
dotnet website
uh there's a big old button on there
that you can click to download uh
there's a little tutorial that shows you
how to do like a little hello world app
things like that
um but this will give you the dynacore
installation to sort of get going
um and in the channel i will post some
links
for how you can get started specifically
with jupiter notebooks vs code notebooks
um and fsharp for the web so
thank you very much uh this has been
pretty good and i'm glad that the
the dev build that i've been using for
the demo didn't totally blow up in my
face right as i was presenting so
uh my prayer to the demo gods was heard
uh
and thank you all for attending um
i have looks like a few more minutes
um so what i will do is
check to see if i have any questions so
far
um somebody said let the cat
in uh let's see let's see what's going
on
no
unfortunately richard um the cat doesn't
want to come in right now she's looking
very cute just outside the door and
that's that's the way that she's gonna
be i guess
um sorry i i wish there was a big old
fuzzball that i could just hold up to
the camera and say oh look how cute this
guy is um
um let's see looking forward to f sharp
five yes i'm also looking forward to f
sharp five
uh it's it's been a lot of work going
into it so far
and uh um i'm really excited
for later this year um when we can
uh finalize some of it oh speaking you
know oh hello
come here here we go
we got the kitty she came here after all
she's a little she's a little camera shy
um
see working on a python parser and f
sharp that's really cool yeah i'd like
to hear about that
um yeah so uh
yeah i think the other thing is there
there's sort of a road map for sure five
if you will
um we are you know we're trying to so i
i actually have on my to-do list for
this week to write another blog post for
the.net blog
i'm going to just sort of talk about a
few additional little tweaks for the
latest donna 5 preview that we've done
and lay out i think a little bit more
things that we're planning for the next
set of previews and then right now we're
still in the preview cycle
so um every month there's a done at five
preview
and in that dot five preview there's
some updates to f5
uh later this year we're probably
thinking around maybe august
um we're going to be closing down on f
sharp five
and uh really just focus focusing on
stabilizing what we have and so
when that happens um we'll
be a blog post that that sort of recaps
all the things that are available and
it'll it'll start to it'll emphasize a
lot more like how to use it in jupyter
notebooks and using ebs code notebooks
things like that
um so
uh yeah i think i think at that point
like right now
it's it's at a point where if you want
to preview some stuff try it out
just sort of get a feel for how using
f-sharp in this space
is like it's definitely good for that um
but later this year is when things are
going to be stabilizing some more
and you will be able to sort of
legitimately do some work with f sharp
five and
you know have have what you're doing be
supported
okay let's see you got another question
here from oday um hope i pronounced your
name correctly
um can you comment on how to mix say
python and f sharp in a notebook
that's a good question this is something
that we're still trying to figure out
okay caramel um sorry my cat's name is
caramel
so that's why i said that um so how can
can i come out and how to mix say python
and a sharpened output
so today um i don't think it
there might be a dev build that i could
throw together that shows it working but
it doesn't quite work yet
um what we're going to ultimately be
doing
is um
exporting some stuff actually you know
what let me
let me just very briefly do this
um do some some some nonsense right here
okay so i'm going to create a cell we're
going to call it a ship interaction
call it message hello
my cat is named
caramel okay oh
oops i typed that doesn't work
okay shift enter okay i got a message
now i'm in c sharp interactive so i'm
gonna go
shebang share from
f sharp message
display
i think i typed this right cool there we
go so
um let's just walk through what i just
did here so this is
f sharp code and i have a value called
message
all right this is c sharp interactive
actually that is executing in this cell
and i have this this special command
called share dash dash from
f sharp and then the name of the the
value we're calling it variable sharing
and i can just use it from c sharp this
is
kind of the way that we're going to be
sort of trying to share things
right so you can imagine instead of this
being a c um
cell this could be a python cell and
maybe there's a shebang here we're not
quite sure on the design yet it might be
you know this special comment that sort
of says hey you can share this value
or there may be like a magic value that
you can access right maybe there's like
a variable or like a handle to the
notebook itself and you could say okay
in the notebook find me the f sharp
values and then get me the value that
has this particular name
um you know it might be something might
look something like this you know
dot values dot f
dot get value
something from f sharp right
and you know i might be able to type
something like that in python code and
then get the value and start doing stuff
and under the covers
this something from f sharp would be
serialized as json and then so this get
value would actually deserialize the
json
um into something that python could
understand
there's there's still some design work
that we're going to have to do to sort
of enable that and get it into
a place that we um are happy with
so i don't know if mixing python and
xsharp in the same notebook is something
that's going to ship his ga
um like that capability might be preview
later this year whereas the rest of
everything else is ga
um but this is like one of the major
things that we want to go after because
we definitely recognize that you can't
like in a lot of cases you can't just go
all in on.net and and f sharp you have
to mix different things together
and we want to make that as frictionless
as possible so
um that was my long-winded answer but
hopefully it gives a little bit of
insight into
what we're trying to do
okay so i got like one more minute left
um so here's the deal it's the morning
for me right now
i actually woke up at six to be able to
give this talk
once this talk is over i will be eating
some breakfast uh
but then after that i will be in the um
the slack for the rest of the day to
take some further questions you can dm
me
directly here uh the name should just be
philip carter
um or you know uh i i think there's
there's like you know if you want to set
up some sort of uh you know specific
chat with me or something like that
um the the fine folks here at ndc can
set that up for us
and i'm happy to answer any questions
talk in further detail about things that
sort of stuff
okay well my time is up
so i think i will
stop sharing my screen here
and
there we go all right that worked pretty
well actually i'm surprised that there
were
not too many hiccups aside from just
that one uh you know my screen share
just sort of disappearing for a brief
moment so
thank you very much uh for for attending
and
um yeah i'll see you around